greg rosenthal nfl network around the
league podcast
joining the show not sure if he's loose
off the boots or not but are you
celebrating tb12's birthday greg
i am not but you know it's nice as a as
a man in my
early 40s to see someone also at the top
of their career like tom brady doing
well
yeah how does that make you feel to to
see tom brady at 44 years young go out
there and probably have more
as many touchdowns this year as years on
this earth
it's interesting as we're starting to
get older than some of these
professional athletes isn't it
uh it is weird you know and i grew up a
patriots fan too uh so it's more just
like
amazing to think that that same 2019
second half of the year tom brady uh who
was surrounded by really
bad uh patriots players just lighting it
up as a top five quarterback i
really remember a 2011 playoff game when
they walked to the ravens that people
said
well there's the end of the patriots
dynasty and now here we are
a decade later you mentioned the
patriots and
talking about what they have going on
right now
where do you stand in terms of
expectations for this team to really
compete with buffalo and the division as
well as make a run back to the playoffs
in the afc look at buffalo
defense looks like it did for most of
the time
uh that sean mcdermott's been there
bounces back a little to me they're
they're the afc favorites they're right
there with
kc and and i don't think the patriots
stand up to that on either
side of the ball but on defense they've
added so much talent
i think all the attention was on the
often uh but their defense was more
disappointing had a bigger collapse last
year and to me with bill belichick's
track record the secondary that they
have in the pieces that they have in the
front seven like that should be a top
ten defense that should be
potentially a top five defense if they
get a decent offense
uh out of cam newton or mack jones i
think they're
a wild card type of team i think they
bounce back a little bit from where they
were last year
greg rosenzal joins the show ben line's
in for rich the rich eisen show i can't
believe we're
48 hours away or so from football we're
gonna have the hall of fame game
this week tj's dallas cowboys and the
pittsburgh steelers
yesterday mike florio was on and we were
talking about how the situation in
pittsburgh
could turn pretty ugly pretty fast what
are you expecting from pittsburgh
as big ben heads into his last season
you know mike
uh my old boss you know he's kind of a
closet steelers fan and he went to
school there he grew up there
i think like steelers fans are thinking
that like thinking the worst case
scenario i
i try to take a a look back and remember
um
this team won twelve games last year if
you just stack up their front seven
talent on defense i'd put it with any
team in the nfl if you stack up
uh their skill position talent receivers
tight ends running back now without your
hair
i put it with top five of the nfl i also
look at mike thomas track record
literally never had a losing record and
i i think
people are assuming that things are
going to fall apart a little too quickly
the offensive line can't get worse i i'm
not saying they're the afc north
favorites
uh but i've just learned not to count
out this tomlin team and they
tend to do better in seasons uh if you
look
through their history under tomlin where
people aren't expecting much and i i
think they'll be right there as a
potential playoff team let's head to the
nfc
greg i'm a big rams fan out here in los
angeles devastating news obviously with
cam
acres what can we expect from matthew
stafford i have no idea if he's truly
elite
we'll get them over the top in the
toughest division in football
or if they're gonna be you know
squandering to
to make the playoffs yeah i i don't know
either my dog
i live in l.a too now until my
daughter's a big ranch man i let her
kind of just jump side for my patriots i
um
i think the expectations so high for
stafford that it's almost a little
unfair
the defense to me is is probably going
to take a step back just because they
were so good and you're replacing
brandon's daily with raheem
i think stafford is more of a test on
sean mcvay
i feel like we know who stafford was if
he was you know
to use your word elite like we'd know by
now
he's been in the league for a decade
doesn't mean he can't be incredibly
productive and be a top seven eight type
of quarterback but to me it's
it's on mcvay to make this work they
showed a lot
of faith in that offensive line by not
making any changes they believe in that
offensive line and i certainly think uh
you know from what i hear about the sean
jackson how he's looked at training camp
uh in the receivers that they have that
they have enough weapons
and they have a coach that i think has a
lot of confidence in his ability to
schema plays
but i don't see them as some heavy
favorite to me that's the best division
in football
and i i don't see them uh really any
different than a year ago the difference
to me is that the 49ers should be much
better so i think there's three teams in
that division
that all have a chance to win the
conference and that's tough when when
you have to play each other two times uh
each
greg rosenthal joins the show nfl
network around the league
podcast ben line's in for rich on the
rich eisen show
you went from the best division in
football the nfc west who
was no doubt the worst division last
season the nfc
east uh when you look at the nfc east
with tj's dallas cowboys
you see them as the favorite in the
division or you rolling with rich in the
washington football team
i'm with ray i mean it's his show so i
guess i got it come on
crazy i don't say whatever you want he's
not here we could have
breakfast for dinner we do whatever we
want no i do agree with rich although
you know
i'm not a you know i work for the nfl
i'm not allowed to um
you know pick these but i can't make
predictions i i'm surprised that the
eagles and the giants
are such big underdogs in this division
if you kind of look at the odds
uh to me any one of these four teams
could have a chance because
things could go sideways with washington
but uh i i've watched such a boring
washington team for
20 years now and i i think the talent
that fitzpatrick has around them
i think their their offensive
coordinator scott turner is actually
pretty underrated
can can dial up some good plays uh that
with that defense to me they are the
favorite because they are the most
complete teams but if you told me
we're going into week 16 and all four of
these teams
are near 500 and they all have a shot
and that's including the eagles who have
a pretty good looking defensive line a
great looking offensive line like that
that wouldn't shock me either
if this is like a 48 race greg every day
now we're at that time of the year
there's a highlight that goes around
from camp
and it gets people fired up i mean
chris brockman almost spilled his
lavender kombucha because he saw kyle
pitts catch a touchdown in practice
but greg you saw that kyle pitts
touchdown i mean come on
it was pretty sweet yeah so advice for
fans not to lose their minds on any
highlights or any on the flip side any
injury news that comes out at
camps right now this is the time of year
where fans emotions can be very up and
down
yeah especially this first week so pads
came on for
i think 29 teams today so
bill belichick would would say that this
first week of camp isn't even football
bruce aryan
soccer practice and that it's still sort
of in the evaluation and teaching period
and literally the competition
that they've been waiting for uh since
may when they were on the field at ota
starts today and so i i never put too
much into the evaluations of who's up
who's down the injuries are different
the injuries i i think are significant
and you can start to
you can start to look at some team
sideways like like your
cowboys who who insist the marcus
lawrence's back surgery is insignificant
he's been out seven months
uh amari cooper they insist his ankle
injury not significant he had that
surgery
seven months ago i mean you you rehab an
injury after a major
major surgery for seven months as an
elite athlete and you're still not a
hundred percent like to me
these are significant signs that we
learn as this month wears on something
to keep an eye on it and
and you look at the cults today learning
that that um uh
their guard quentin nelson is going to
be out for at least a month or two
uh those are the things that start to
set you back before the season even
starts
greg rosenthal joins the show ben lyon's
in for rich on the rich eisen show you
can catch greg of course on nfl network
and
around the league we got for greg there
brockman
did you see this thread that ralph
vacchiano had about giants practice
today greg
what is going on over there and like joe
judges makes these guys run sprints like
he's heard brooks like
i've never seen anything like it i i
am amazed by it um that he made them run
sprint after in
all out after all right on the field
and not just a fight because you know
those those happen at almost all
training camps
some coaches have a pretty locked down
where you really aren't allowed to do it
um but that happened but this one
supposedly
had like 20 people in it and daniel
jones your quarterback
is is at the bottom and then yeah you're
punishing them by by running around the
field like
it's a fine line where whether you're
going to keep your players uh
engaged with that kind of attitude with
joe judge and
and it looks like a team you know when
that does happen that he doesn't have a
total uh amount of control and that's
what he's looking for
yeah but greg you've been someone who's
covering the nfl for a long time i would
imagine it's just going to blow over the
new york media
no i know we get we got nothing to do
with
it's early august people are hungry like
fans
reporters we haven't been at uh training
camp in this sort of way now for
for two years so we're loving it use i
like the fights when the teams practice
with each other though that's always
like
chargers saints they practice every year
if you show up on the first day you have
a guaranteed couple fights if you go
there for free
but jason garrett was there was someone
had a photo of him and he had a t-shirt
in the giants
font that said fight it was like he was
expecting it
it's mixed messages um maybe that
offense is
is frustrated because from what i've
heard and granted it
it's the first week no one's tackling or
anything that often has been working
right now
the defense is dominating every day that
happens early in training camp a lot but
uh
this is an offense i think under garrett
that has a lot of pressure on it are
they added a lot of pieces kenny
gallagher went out of practice with an
injury today we'll see if that's serious
but daniel jones all those weapons and
you have garrett which you know i'm sure
um you know the cowboys fan there is
like
i don't know if he's the guy to like
come up with a lot of creative stuff
when you have all these different pieces
on the perimeter that the giant did greg
rosenthal joins the show nfl network
around the league podcast yeah greg what
can we expect out of jameis is he really
going to be the guy down there for new
orleans and
will they even beat the bucks i mean
come on
i um you know saw michael thomas is
going to be out for a while and they
have a great offensive line
they have they have murray i mean a
camara and they have others murray and i
thought like
is sean payton going to be tempted here
to start paying taysom hill
you know he loves them he's paying him
uh run the ball a lot and rely on their
defense i think that's a possibility but
when you look at jameis winston
i try not to put too much in like he's
in the best shape of his life stuff but
he looks like a different person i mean
he had to have lost 30 or 40 pounds from
from his peak i don't know if that's
going to make him a better player but he
certainly got the arm he's got the
the coach now um i mean he's got the
production this guy's
you know put up seven thousand yards uh
way more than that in his career
uh 7.8 yards per time they got to give
him a chance i think because the upside
is so much higher than you would have
with jason hill but i don't know if
it'll be week one
yesterday greg it was just kind of
understood and decided that nick foles
is gonna go replace carson once again
this time in indianapolis hasn't
happened just yet
but do you see that happening and is
that the best path forward for the cults
now that carson's on the shelf for a
while
i i don't see it happening i think
they're gonna
see how whence recovers they're no hurry
whatsoever and that if they did make a
move for a veteran
it might not be false i really think
they will be cognizant
of whence's feelings and inviting
that whole trauma back uh into the cult
like i i think they're more likely to
look at a guy
if if they really need to because once
is in a hundred percent
like a jacobi percent who they've had
before in miami or maybe they call up
the raiders and see what it would take
to get
mariota but it it's a mess because their
offensive line right now is banged up
carson wentz to me is not a an
attractive starting quarterback
unless he has his athleticism he's got
his own he's got troubles when he's 100
healthy and i i think they've certainly
won the award for kind of the worst
week one of training camp and i i don't
think paul's going there he pitched
himself to go there but he's got
guaranteed money into next year and i
don't think the colts
necessarily want to pay that hey greg
before we let you go a lot of talk being
made about tyreek hill versus usain bolt
in a race you saw dk metcalf trying to
make the olympics uh
came up a little short when you're
watching these olympic games do you
think about which nfl players would do
well for example how do you think aaron
donald would do in the hammer throw
with like training so life i could see
it like he's got the footwork which they
kind of need on top of that strength it
looks like he would have to gain even
more weight i always laugh though when
they talk about like the tracks usain
bolt
and the nfl players thinking they can be
i mean these track athletes please let's
have some respect they they are no joke
and none of these nfl players are going
to be
uh competing with them marquise goodwin
i guess would be the only one i'd give a
nod to who actually did make the
olympics back in the day
who wins the quarterback triple jump
challenge tannehill
man i think lamar like the rangy
uh springy uh speed that he would have
like approaching that um
i feel like lamar jackson could do
anything if you put him in basically any
sport
greg appreciate the insight on the
hypothetical quarterback triple jump
as well as football games that will be
played next month thank you so much
i know i i answered it very seriously
you really did question
for what it was expert analysis there's
no other show
across american sports media today where
you're going to get an nfl network
analyst
breaking down lamar jackson's triple
jump potential well yesterday
yesterday we were talking about sports
reporter survivor so like how would you
do in survivor greg
oh man well i always would back myself
i'm small
you you brockman knows i'm a little guy
but i'm wiry like i don't need that much
food to last a long time
i run long distances like i can outlast
people they won't see me coming
yeah but greg i kind of see you as a
glamper no can you really get down and
dirty out there in the wilderness so you
need that
tent to be you know have wi-fi i can't
say i have a lot of practice uh doing
this but i i'm just
i think my mental toughness is gonna
carry me good stuff good stuff thanks
greg
appreciate it that guy loves to compete
greg greg rosenthal
you never hear guys who aren't
professional athletes be described as oh
you got to go out on a date with my
friend john he's a really great guy he
loves to compete he's got a good job
i'm adding that to my bio on twitter my
twitter bio loves to compete
greg rosen's all talking about this
mental edge and his wiry frames
surviving in the wilderness
[Laughter]
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here